jenny frank julian aminés sont des
adhérents fidèles au club bois
handisport ils ont découvert le hockey
luge cet automne et sont devenus
complètement accro malgré les
difficultés le basket on a en fauteuil
on a deux pouces et on a un ballon
ici on est au ras du sol on a du mal à
rouler de faire des passes entre une
feinte sport j'aime bien c'est physique
et on aime bien les choses physiques et
différence entre nous engagement
[Musique]
le principe est simple en apparence une
luge à des roulettes qu'il faut faire
avancer avec sa crosse mais dans les
faits c'est très technique et physique
jenny est privé de ses jambes depuis un
accident de hand en prédisant de kayak
ce nouveau sport est un vrai défi c'est
vraiment super j'adore ça j'adore le
contraire
en fait je suis incomplète j'ai une
pénalité des cervicales
je n'ai pas tous mes abdominaux juste
quelques uns
la difficulté pour moi c'est pas que je
peut basculer grâce à des petites
astuces de bricolage les luges sont
adaptés à chacun mais l'activité n'est
pas réservé aux personnes en situation
de handicap l'idée et de la partager
avec les valides
c'est très très plaisant qu'au niveau du
corps non ça c'est qu'ils sont habitués
à être en fauteuil sont beaucoup plus
rapides que nous est-ce que là ils
entendent valide tous les tons sont
moins sollicités pour la propulsion donc
on pour un peu derrière au début dès
qu'on commence à comprendre
il ya vraiment un petit bémol pour le
moment le club loi handisport ne dispose
que de dix luge cette discipline coûte
cher dix neuf mille euros d'équipements
fabriqués au canada est financée
uniquement par les dons des partenaires
privés et des particuliers
le club rêve d'en avoir plus et ses
adhérents aussi
à